[Music]
Captain Marvel and Miss Marvel and
Monica Rambo oh my that's just one of
five picks this week along with the
mcu's Final Phase five film of the year
we've got a movie starring Nicholas Cage
a movie starring Michael fast Bender a
movie starring Paul Giamatti and a
series starring Emma Stone what more do
you need snacks snacks is the answer
that's what you're looking for it's all
coming up on this week's what to watch
Nick Fury my favorite oneeyed man of
intrigue how goes it out there you know
cold no air space taking over theaters
is the latest MCU offering the Marvels
the first reason to fly if you can or
run to theaters is that this gosh darn
thing is finally out arriving after a
few delays and story changes and that's
a good thing cuz it serves as a sequel
to not only the movie Captain Marvel but
also the Disney plus series Miss Marvel
and W division 2 another reason to
Marvel at this one is that it's bringing
together three superheroes at least with
brie larsson's Captain Marvel Iman
Milani's Miss Marvel and Tona Paris as
the superpowered Monica Rambo not a bad
little Trio thirdly the Marvels has been
in good hands with director and
co-writer Nia dasta who has made history
as the first black woman to helm a
Marvel film this comes after she became
the first black female director to debut
at number one at the box office with
202's Candyman clearly it's a name you
need to remember oh you've been on my
mind recently you keep popping up in my
dreams you don't do anything you're just
there also floating into theater is the
a24 comedy dream scenario jumping out
right away as the top reason to see this
one is the film's interesting premise
about a regular family man whose life
takes a crazy turn when he starts
showing up in dreams of millions of
people and enters a new found and
nightmarish stardom another reason to
make this your movie night destination
is its cast led by the one and only
Nicholas Cage and he's joined by folks
like Julian Nicholson Michael Sarah and
Tim Meadows AKA a talented and eccentric
mix to bring the scenario into life if
you're not already sold it's worth
noting that after premiering earlier
this year at the Toronto Film Festival
dream scenario is quite fresh on the
Tomato Meter with over 60 reviews and
Counting and plenty of love going to
Nick Cage's performance as one might
Imagine This Is What It
Takes my
process is purely
logistical also sneaking onto your
screens is the action flick the killer
for reason number one to check this one
out look no fur further than director
David Fincher The Man Behind countless
hits like seven Fight Club and The
Social Network now go ahead and pair
that with reason 1A a cast led by
Michael fast Bender in the title role
and support from Tilda Swinton reason
two is that the Killer is based on the
popular French graphic novel series of
the same name about an assassin battling
his employers and himself on an
international Man Hunt he insists isn't
Personal Plus the film is already
certified fresh on the Tomato Meter with
a critic's consensus that says vure is
on firm footing with a stylish and
engaging Thriller that proves a perfect
match for fast Bender dude yes I had you
got stuck with babysitting duty this
year how'd you manage that you know he
used to be a student right that's why he
knows how to inflict maximum pain on
us I thought all the nais were hiding in
Argentina stifle it tell another option
in theaters got to love this time of
year is the period dramedy the holdovers
this one features another iconic
director star combo with Alexander Payne
at the helm and Paul Giamatti as the
leading man that's the first reason and
a half to consider this another is that
it's a period piece always a fun escape
it's set in the 1970s and follows a
history teacher Giamatti at a New
England Prep School who has to look
after a handful of students who couldn't
go home over Christmas break a plus it's
worth noting that after premiering at
the tell you ride film festival in late
August the holdovers has received plenty
of critical Acclaim and love for
director Payne what is that that's
nothing this is you don't need to see
this why did you snatch back the money
why didn't you just give her the hun I
was going to buy six of them for $20 I
curse you what did she say and finally
keeping you on your couch this week is a
comedy series The Curse the main reason
to watch this show is that it was
created and written by comedian and
actor Nathan Fielder along with
filmmaker and actor Benny softi part of
the softy Brothers Duo from uncut gems
Fame secondly those two also star in the
curse alongside one Emma Stone and a
Supporting Cast that includes Corbin
burnson and barkot obdi among others a
third reason to find this one on
Showtime or Paramount plus is the
mysterious premise which Chronicles the
way an alleged curse messes with the
lives of a newly wed couple as they star
on an HGTV show and try to have a baby
well there you go five picks that are
filled with cool stories and great
talent you're so welcome be sure to let
us and your fellow viewers know in the
comments what you did check out whether
it was on this list or not remember to
check out Ron tomatoes.com for the
latest updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World at large that's all
for today fresh family until next week
stay
fresh